up until the 1970s cryptography had been
based on symmetric keys that is the
sender encrypts their message using a
specific key and the receiver decrypts
using an identical key as you may recall
encryption is a mapping from some
message using a specific key to a cipher
text message to decrypt the cipher text
you use the same key to reverse the
mapping so for Alice and Bob to
communicate securely they must first
share identical keys
however establishing a shared key is
often impossible if Alice and Bob can't
physically meet or requires extra
communications overhead when using the
diffie-hellman key exchange plus if
Alice needs to communicate with multiple
people perhaps she's a bank then she's
going to have to exchange distinct keys
with each person now she'll have to
manage all of these keys and send
thousands of messages just to establish
them could there be a simpler way in
1970 James Ellis a British engineer and
mathematician was working on an idea for
non-secret encryption it's based on a
simple yet clever concept lock and
unlock are inverse operations Alice
could buy a lock keep the key and send
the open lock to Bob Bob then locks his
message and sends it back to Alice no
keys are exchanged this means she could
publish the lock widely and let anyone
in the world use it to send her a
message
and she now only needs to keep track of
a single key Alice never arrived at a
mathematical solution though he had an
intuitive sense of how it should work
the idea is based on splitting a key
into two parts an encryption key and a
decryption key the decryption key
performs the inverse or undo operation
which was applied by the encryption key
to see how inverse keys could work let's
do a simplified example with colors how
could Bob send Alice a specific color
without Eve who is always listening
intercepting it the inverse of some
color is called a complementary color
which when added to it produces white
undoing the effect of the first color in
this example we assume that mixing
colors is a one-way function because
it's fast to mix colors and output 1/3
and it's much slower to undo Alice first
generates her private key by randomly
selecting a color say red next assume
Alice uses a secret color machine to
find the exact complement of her red and
nobody else has access to this
this results in cyan which she sends to
Bob as her public key let's say Bob
wants to send a secret yellow to Alice
he mixes this with her public color and
sends the resulting mixture back to
Alice
now Alice adds her private color to
Bob's mixture this undoes the effect of
her public color leaving her with Bob's
secret color notice Eve has no easy way
to find Bob's yellow since she needs
Alice's private red to do so this is how
it should work however a mathematical
solution was needed to make this work in
practice the solution was found by
another British mathematician in
cryptographer Clifford Cox
[ __ ] needed to construct a special kind
of one-way function called a trapdoor
one-way function this is a function that
is easy to compute in one direction yet
difficult to reverse unless you have
special information called the trapdoor
for this he turned to modular
exponentiation which we introduced as
clock arithmetic in the diffie-hellman
key exchange as follows
take a number raise it to some exponent
divided by the modulus and output the
remainder this can be used to encrypt a
message as follows imagine Bob has a
message which is converted into a number
M he then multiplies his number by
itself e times where E is a public
exponent then he divides the result by a
random number n and outputs the
remainder of the division this results
in some numbers see this calculation is
easy to perform
however given only C E and n it is much
more difficult to determine which M was
used because we'd have to resort to some
form of trial and error so this is our
one-way function that we can apply to M
easy to perform but difficult to reverse
it is our mathematical lock
now what about the key the key is the
trapdoor some piece of information that
makes it easy to reverse the encryption
we need to raise C to some other
exponent say D which will undo the
initial operation applied to M and
return the original message M so both
operations together is the same as M to
the power of e all raised to the power
of D which is the same as M to the power
of e times D e is the encryption D is
the decryption therefore we need a way
for Alice to construct e and D which
makes it difficult for anyone else to
find D this requires a second one-way
function which is used for generating D
and for this he looked back to Euclid
over 2,000 years ago Euclid showed every
number has exactly one prime
factorization which we can think of as a
secret key it turns out that prime
factorization is a fundamentally hard
problem let's clarify what we mean by
easy and hard by introducing what's
called time complexity we have all
multiplied numbers before and each of us
has our own rules for doing so in order
to speed things up if we program a
computer to multiply numbers it can do
so much faster than any human can here
is a graph that shows the time required
for a computer to multiply two numbers
and of course the time required to find
the answer increases as the numbers get
larger
notice that the computation time stays
well under one second even with fairly
large numbers therefore it is easy to
perform now compare this the prime
factorization if someone told you to
find the prime factorization of 589 you
will notice the problem feels harder no
matter what your strategy it will
require some trial and error until you
find a number which evenly divides 589
after some struggle you will find 19
times 31 is the prime factorization if
you were told to find the prime
factorization of 437,000 to
131 you probably give up and get a
computer to help you this works fine for
small numbers though if we try to get a
computer to factor of larger and larger
numbers there is a runaway effect the
time needed to perform the calculations
increases rapidly as there are more
steps involved as the numbers grow the
computer needs minutes then hours and
eventually will require hundreds or
thousands of years to factor huge
numbers we therefore say it is a hard
problem due to this growth rate of time
needed to solve it so factorization is
what Cox used to build the trapdoor
solution step 1 imagine Alice randomly
generated a prime number over 150 digits
long call this p1 then a second random
prime number roughly the same size call
this p2 she then multiplies these two
Prime's together to get a composite
number n which is over 300 digits long
this multiplication step would take less
than a second we could even do it in a
web browser
then she takes the factorization of n p1
times p2 and hides it now if she gave n2
anyone else they would have to have a
computer running for years to find the
solution step 2
Cox needed to find a function which
depends on knowing the factorization of
n for this he looked back to work done
in 1760 by Swiss mathematician Leonardo
Euler Euler continue to investigate
properties of numbers specifically the
distribution of prime numbers one
important function he defined is called
the Phi function it measures the break
ability of a number so given a number
say n it outputs how many integers are
less than or equal to n that do not
share any common factor with n for
example if we want to find the Phi of 8
we look at all values from 1 to 8 then
we count how many integers 8 does not
share a factor greater than 1 with
notice 6 is not counted because it
shares a factor of 2 well 1 3 5 and 7
are all counted because they only share
factor of 1 therefore Phi of 8 equals 4
what's interesting is that calculating
the Phi function is hard except in one
case look at this graph it is a plot of
values of Phi over integers from 1 to a
thousand now notice any predictable
pattern the straight line of points
along the top represent all the prime
numbers since prime numbers have no
factors greater than 1 the Phi of any
prime number P is simply P minus 1 to
calculate Phi of 7 a prime number we
count all integers except 7 since none
of them share a factor with 7 Phi of 7
equals 6
so if you're asked to find Phi of 20
1377 a prime number you would only need
to subtract 1 to get the solution 20
1376 Phi of any prime is easy to compute
this leads to an interesting result
based on the fact that the Phi function
is also multiplicative that is Phi a
times B equals Phi a times Phi B if we
know some number n is the product of two
primes P 1 and P 2 then Phi of n is just
the value of Phi for each prime
multiplied together or P 1 minus 1 times
P 2 minus 1 we now have a trapdoor for
solving Phi if you know the
factorization for n then finding Phi n
is easy for example the prime
factorization of 77 is 7 times 11 so Phi
of 77 is 6 times 10 60 step 3 how to
connect the Phi function to modular
exponentiation for this he turned to
euler's theorem which is a relationship
between the Phi function and modular
exponentiation as follows m to the power
of Phi n is congruent to 1 mod n this
means you could pick any two numbers
such that they do not share a common
factor let's call them m and n say m
equals 5 and N equals 8 now when you
raise m to the power of Phi N or 4 and
divide by n you will always be left with
1 now we just need to modify this
equation using two simple rules first if
you raise the number 1 to any exponent K
you always get 1 in the same way we can
multiply the exponent Phi n by any
number K and the solution is still one
second if you multiply 1 by any number
say M it always equals M in the same way
we can multiply the left side by n to
get em on the right-hand side
and this can be simplified as m ^ k
times Phi n plus 1 this is the
breakthrough we now have an equation for
finding e times D which depends on Phi n
therefore it's easy to calculate D only
if the factorization of n is known
meaning D should be Alice's private key
it's the trapdoor which will allow her
to undo the effect of e let's do a
simple example to see all of this in
action say Bob has a message he
converted into a number using a padding
scheme let's call this N then Alice
generates her public and private key as
follows
first she generates two random prime
numbers of similar size and multiplies
them to get n 3127 then she calculates
Phi of n easily since she knows the
factorization of n which turns out to
three thousand and sixteen next she
picks some small public exponent e with
the condition that it must be an odd
number that does not share a factor with
Phi n in this case she picks e equals
three finally she finds the value of her
private exponent D which in this case is
two times Phi of n plus one divided by
three or 2011 now she hides everything
except the value of N and E because N
and E make up her public key think of it
as an open lock she sends this to Bob to
lock his message with Bob locks his
message by calculating m ^ e mod n call
this see his encrypted message which he
sends back to Alice
finally Alice decrypts his message using
her private key d accessed through her
trap door C ^ D mod N equals Bob's
original message M notice that Eve or
anyone else with C N and E can only find
the
exponent D if they can calculate Phi n
which requires that they know the prime
factorization of n if n is large enough
Alice can be sure that this will take
hundreds of years even with the most
powerful network of computers this trick
was immediately classified after its
publication however it was independently
rediscovered in 1977 by Ron Rivest Adi
Shamir and Len Adelman which is why it's
now known as RSA encryption RSA is the
most widely used public key algorithm in
the world and the most copied software
in history every Internet user on earth
is using RSA or some variant of it
whether they realize it or not its
strength relies on the hardness of prime
factorization which is a result of deep
questions about the distribution of
prime numbers a question which has
remained unsolved for thousands of years